who comes up with these recipes if I put
chocolate on my baby my mum would kill
me
she loved you until she saw this mess
right welcome to Next Level kitchen
where we are taking your skills to the
next level teaching you the basics the
most amazing tips to help elevate your
cooking
and today we're peering inside your
cupboard showing you how to make some
delicious dishes on a budget and trust
me unlike any Back Garden Paul I promise
you I know your back Garden's full of
seafood today you're going to be cooking
A protein that is familiar around the
world yeah it's humble it's cheap it's
delicious ground beef beef now right
what are you doing right I'm gonna do a
chili con carne but I'm going to give
you loads and loads of tips with a
beautiful baked jacket potato sour cream
and cheddar cheese I love that uh I'm
gonna do almost like a rice bowl but
with a nice savory mint some pickled
vegetables and that good old fried egg
yeah listen the first tip I want to give
you is I'm going to bake the mince hold
on I'm gonna tell your old boss Marcus
you're baking mince yes all right this
is a fantastic tip so mince straight
onto the tray we've got cumin where did
you learn that by the way smoke paprika
wait wait wait wait think about it
Gordon right I am I'm nervous sea salt
yes okay and a good pepper right so
normally yes you would get the mints
into the pan this stage you'd be
hammering it with a wooden spoon all of
the water would be coming out the mints
this way it doesn't happen you bake it
in the oven and the mint just bakes all
that fat comes out wow almost goes like
crispy beef and then fold it into your
sauce your basically you're basically
reversing how you make the chili con
carne have you got you've got no stove
at home what you're listening you've got
no stove at home you're baking meat I've
never seen mince on a tray ever you're
about to be wow this is taking your
chili con carne to the next level love
that right um so just like that so
you've got the smoked paprika the
cinnamon and the cumin a good seasoning
of salt and pepper and straight into the
oven 180 degrees and bake it till it
goes nice and crispy okay so he's baking
his mince I'm gonna fry my mince if I
bake my mince my mum would kick my ass
okay hot pan okay why because I want
some color on my mince salt and pepper I
always like to season it seconds before
it goes into the wok okay why
because literally you want to cook and
season as you go Min straight in
I'm gonna fry this mince now
hey you're moving fast with that knife
there kiddo oh
now this is how to cook mince in a wok I
could be lazy and
stick it in the oven and sort of go and
play on the beach with the kids but no
I'm going to show you how to make the
most amazing mince okay now spread that
mince up the size of the bowl okay like
I said it's a sort of Rich sticky mince
that's the noise you want to hear I'm
gonna lightly season that with a touch
of chili I start off an oil and now look
got a little bit butter around the
outside of the wok and start
caramelizing that mince
caramelizing not baking see it's all
right look you see all all that water
and all that no it's coming out no
that's that's what happened with me that
is Flavor now chop that up and it starts
to go individual so therefore it starts
to caramelize beautifully and this is
where the magic starts to lift Sriracha
okay around the outside of your Wok now
all we're doing is coating that mince
okay
teaspoon of sriracha a little bit of soy
sauce just a nice teaspoon that's going
to give a really nice salty dark flavor
to that mince a touch a sesame seed oil
Just a Touch
and then of course a little bit of fish
sauce now you start to see this mint
coming together beautifully okay
that's what we seasoned with
chopped garlic
and chopped Ginger
now watch that mince come together Paul
you good yes very good right okay so you
see now I've roasted these onions right
down I've just seasoned them with salt
and pepper really important to get that
seasoning right at the beginning draw
that flavor out and that moisture so
those onions go nice and caramelized
how's the baked mince is you ate you
wait next I'm gonna add in garlic here
I've got four cloves all right so nice
and Punchy nice and strong next dried
oregano wow okay next we're gonna add in
cumin yes
chili powder yes okay
and now just get those spices in with
those onions yes garlic and cook that
for about another three or four minutes
where's the mince the mints
right um I've got a little bit of a um
a cooling pickled vegetables so I've got
some nicely chopped carrots you can
grate them I like to take the skin off
the Cucumber remove the seeds that's all
the water okay therefore we can just
taste pure cucumber
and here's where it starts to go up a
level for me my eggs are frying nice and
carefully I've sprinkled them with some
really nice chili and now all we do is
chop the Cucumber
and the vegetables
slip over to me Gordon please I need 30
seconds please seriously because I'm not
baking my cucumber I'm topping it
chopped cucumber in I'm going to flip
over to Paul azler with these baked
mince okay baked beans right no bake
whoa here see all that steam that's all
that flavor just disappearing okay my
flavor is going right into the mince
this in the pan now I've just added
tomato puree yes a teaspoon cooking it
out yes and some Demerara sugar okay
what sugar two teaspoons of Demerara
sugar yes where's Deborah frog Deborah
Deborah Harris oh gotcha you always know
when he's rattled because he tries to
make other words he knows that I have
outdone with this tip because that mince
is boiling away tasteless flavors
disappearing into the canopy what what
right now next no can you pass it back
over in a minute I miss you you're a
tomato
I'm surprised you're not giving it the
pan down
look at that I'm more concerned about
your mints in the oven you wait you wait
right uh quick particular vegetables
carrots cucumber chili flakes salt and
sugar and a little touch of mirin okay
from there lift that up with some fresh
lime always roll that lime first okay
that's going to maximize the juice and
then squeeze that fresh lime in I'm
dying to see this baked mint kid here we
have that beautiful sauce now reduced
right yes all that flavor locked in all
of those spices next I'm going to take
black beans this is my personal
preference classically kidney beans but
you know what use whatever beans you've
got in your store cupboard I'm using
black beans
all right
now have I got time to show show my
mints show your your mints can I show
you my Meats I would love to see your
mince right can you
listen rather than taking the fish just
listen to this dip I'm desperate to see
your mint okay look at that all right
crispy beef mince all that spice it's
gone really really crispy right so loads
of loads of Flavor now it almost
rehydrates itself back in the sauce I'm
gonna apologize the mince is delicious
there's no butts but right here we go so
now I'm just folding look at that sauce
now just coating that beautiful crispy
mince now spring onions we're getting
close to me finishing this dish what
already yes right so again do not Chuck
the green bits away we're gonna we're
gonna chop these down think of them
almost like large chives so the green
end of the spring onion is going to go
in our beautiful delicious chili so that
looks delicious are you rehydrating that
mince now I love that love that
okay right no have a taste please it's
hot
yes delicious you know that you know
absolutely delicious so mint caramelized
you okay yeah I'm good minced
caramelized take it away
take all the way down to a glaze really
important and the flavors off with the
gas
and over here
I've got my leftover rice I've
rehydrated and just steamed it and so
how we present this is we just let that
rice
sit naturally on the plate and this is
where it really goes
to the next level
Gordon can I just interrupt you and you
can enter another Next Level tip
absolutely so you see here I've got the
green of the spring onions yes did you
like beautiful chili did you know I'm
just gonna finish it with 70 dark
chocolate all right absolutely delicious
chocolate on your mince yeah no trust me
no no we're gonna get fired no we're not
now we're gonna lose our job no we're
not gonna lose our jobs chocolate on
your mince yes just it's bitter it's
lovely and it just gives your chili an
absolutely amazing mouthfeel
no you've lost with haircut
chocolate on my menu trust me now
generally I promise you don't drain this
just spoon it's beautiful
spicy fried mince okay and then from
there
All I'm gonna do now
is let that
rice soak up all that beautiful mince
come on you know you want some
and what I'm not gonna do on here is put
any chocolate on there and then look
my beautiful chili fried eggs
I'm using a little bit of that
fat from the eggs going on
I'm not I'm just gonna drizzle that over
the rice
and then finally
I got this really nice
pickled light vegetable turn that around
take one nice lump on and just sit it on
the side and trust me
that is delicious a beautiful
crispy
beef rice bowl with some wonderful
pickled vegetables Paul right ready all
right kid okay please so now I'm just
going to spoon this gorgeous chili over
the top of my jacket potato
all right just try that did the jacket
potatoes go in the oven the jacket
potatoes were in the oven with the mints
all right okay
for me all of those lovely spices the
cumin the smoked paprika the chili yes
all right next just cool it down and
keep it nice and fresh with that spice
we're just taking a little dollop of
sour cream over the top
then because we're using everything
those spring onions
so that's the base of the spring onions
cheese
all over
and then we just finish it
with a little bit more chocolate oh no
yeah no no no yeah no no absolutely no
seriously all right and a nice glug
chocolate olive oil chocolate on your
baked potato kid it's next level okay
hit me
there you go
weekday meal right there chili con carne
Jack potato sour cream cheddar cheese
[Music]
you got me on the chocolate now listen
let's be honest that works you know it
does uh you're right you're I'm not
gonna argue with the Youth of today
trust me now that's how you take your
dishes to the next level so to get the
ingredients and for more details on
these amazing dishes from tonight then
check in the description below and be
sure to subscribe for more episodes of
Next Level kitchen well done
thank you